Hey friends, it's Jillian from the teach me how to add all podcast if like me you're looking to travel more this year and make Some extra income on the side. This one is for you We've teamed up with Airbnb to share more about how to be an Airbnb host because you could be sitting in the perfect Airbnb spot right now if you have a spare bedroom Which also side note is such a fun way to meet new people from around the world if you're hosting them Why not make some extra money off of it? Or if you're always traveling like I am it's so easy to just Airbnb your whole place I was out of town for four months out of the year last year with a vacant condo Just sitting there not being used and I've realized how easy it would be to make extra money in the side to cover all of my
大家好，我是《教我如何添加所有播客》（Teach Me How to Add All Podcast）的吉莉安。如果你和我一样，想在今年多去旅行，并赚取一些额外的副业收入，那么这期节目绝对适合你。我们与爱彼迎（Airbnb）合作，向大家分享如何成为一名爱彼迎房东，因为如果你有一间空置的卧室，你现在可能正坐在一个完美的爱彼迎房源里。顺便说一句，这也是一种非常有趣的方式，可以结识来自世界各地的新朋友，如果你正在接待他们，为什么不从中赚取一些额外的钱呢？或者，如果你像我一样经常旅行，把你的整套房子挂在爱彼迎上出租是如此简单。去年我有四个月不在城里，公寓就那样空着，没有任何人使用。我意识到，在我离开期间，只需通过在旅行时成为爱彼迎房东，就能轻松赚取外快来支付我所有的
Travel costs when I'm away just by becoming an Airbnb host when I'm traveling the world I almost exclusively stay in Airbnb's because I like having access to a kitchen Feeling like I'm at home when I'm traveling having all the stuff that you would normally have when you're at home And I love the local recommendation guides that a lot of hosts provide So you can just get to know the area that you're visiting from someone who's actually lived in it I just used Airbnb actually into loom to stay at truly the most luxurious penthouse loft I have I've ever seen it was Such a vibe the aesthetic was incredible the service was fantastic and I loved the privacy of it
旅行开销。当我周游世界时，我几乎只住爱彼迎，因为我喜欢可以使用厨房的感觉，旅行时也能有在家的感觉，拥有你在家时通常拥有的所有东西。而且我很喜欢许多房东提供的当地推荐指南，这样你就可以通过一个真正在那里生活过的人来了解你正在访问的地区。事实上，我最近刚在图卢姆（Tulum）通过爱彼迎入住了一套我见过的最豪华的顶层阁楼，那里的氛围简直绝了，美学令人惊叹，服务棒极了，而且我非常喜欢它的私密性。
Airbnb is such a smart way to use what you already have to generate more income Whether you're saving for a wedding or a big trip somewhere or just trying to cover bills and possibly bump up your income Your home might be worth more than you think so find out how much at Airbnb.ca slash host Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents if you feel at any time you need support Please contact your local crisis center for suggested phone numbers for confidential support Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website In mid 2014 John and Andrea Woods were busy packing up their possessions into moving boxes After living at 657 Boulevard for the past 23 years the time had come for the couple to move on
爱彼迎是一种非常聪明的利用现有资源创造更多收入的方式。无论你是在为婚礼或某次大旅行存钱，还是只是想支付账单并可能提高收入，你的家可能比你想象的更有价值，所以请访问 airbnb.ca/host 了解具体价值。我们的节目涉及严重且通常令人痛苦的事件，如果您在任何时候觉得自己需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用上或我们网站上的本集节目说明。在2014年中期，约翰（John）和安德烈亚·伍兹（Andrea Woods）正忙着将他们的物品打包进搬家箱里。在布勒瓦德（Boulevard）657号住了过去23年之后，这对夫妇搬家的时刻终于到来了。
Located in the affluent suburb of Westfield, New Jersey Their striking six bedroom four bathroom Dutch colonial style home was the perfect house to raise a family Potential buyers would be further encouraged by the area's tight-knit community and low crime rate The Woods hoped that the new owners would settle in quickly to the home they had loved In the days before they moved out John and Andrea Woods received a letter After reading it herself Andrea showed it to John He disregarded it crumpled the paper into a ball and threw it in the trash The letter had been signed by someone claiming to be the Watcher
这栋引人注目的六房四卫荷兰殖民地风格住宅位于新泽西州韦斯特菲尔德（Westfield）富裕的郊区，是抚养家庭的绝佳房子。该地区紧密的社区和极低的犯罪率，更会让潜在买家感到放心。伍兹夫妇希望新业主能迅速安顿下来，住进这座他们一直深爱的房子里。在搬出去前的几天里，约翰和安德烈亚·伍兹收到了一封信。安德烈亚自己读过之后，把它拿给约翰看。约翰没放在心上，把纸揉成一团扔进了垃圾桶。这封信的落款是一个自称是“守望者”（The Watcher）的人。
Music Derrig Broadus stepped through the front door of 657 Boulevard His wife Maria had grown up in the suburb and the two could think of nowhere better to raise their three young children Although they had taken out a hefty mortgage on the nearly $1.4 million house the Broadus' couldn't be more excited It was their dream home Built in 1905 the house required some renovations The couple decided to stay in their current residence and get all the necessary work done before moving in Built across 3920 square feet the multi-story house sat at the end of a long curved driveway
音乐。德里克·布罗杜斯（Derek Broadus）跨过布勒瓦德657号的正门。他的妻子玛丽亚（Maria）在这个郊区长大，两人觉得没有比这更好的地方来抚养他们三个年幼的孩子了。尽管他们为这栋价值近140万美元的房子背负了沉重的房贷，但布罗杜斯一家还是兴奋不已。这是他们的梦想之家。这栋房子建于1905年，需要进行一些翻修。这对夫妇决定住在当前的住所，并在搬进去之前完成所有必要的工作。这栋多层住宅占地3920平方英尺，坐落在一个长长的弧形车道尽头。
A white-columned porch, large bay windows and intricate wood and stonework defined the stately residence It was surrounded by an expanse of manicured lawn dotted with lush trees and a well-maintained garden The Broadus' children aged 10, 8 and 5 played in the yard while Derrig and Maria got to work planning their renovations Three days after settlement in June 2014 Derrig spent the afternoon and evening alone painting the interior of the house Just before 10pm as he was preparing to leave Derrig checked the mailbox He pulled out a handful of envelopes, mostly bills and some pamphlets Amongst the mail was a handwritten envelope addressed to the new owner It was written with a thick black pen, there was no return address
白色立柱门廊、大型飘窗以及错综复杂的木作和石雕勾勒出这座庄严住宅的轮廓。它被大片修剪整齐的草坪所环绕，草坪上点缀着郁郁葱葱的树木和一个维护良好的花园。布罗杜斯一家的三个孩子（分别10岁、8岁和5岁）在院子里玩耍，而德里克和玛丽亚则开始着手规划他们的翻修工作。2014年6月交房三天后，德里克独自度过了下午和晚上，粉刷房子的内部。就在晚上10点之前，当他准备离开时，德里克检查了邮箱。他掏出一把信件，大部分是账单和小册子。在这些邮件中，有一封手写的信封，收件人是新业主。信封是用粗黑笔写的，没有回信地址。
Derrig opened the envelope After reading the letter on his porch Derrig Broadus ran back inside and locked the door behind him He turned off all the lights so the house appeared unoccupied from the street Grabbing the phone he dialed the number for the Westfield Police Department An officer was dispatched to 657 Boulevard and read the letter Derrig presented to him Once he'd finished reading the officer looked up at Derrig with a perplexed expression He asked, what the fuck is this? The typed letter read
德里克打开了信封。在门廊上读完信后，德里克·布罗杜斯跑回屋里，反锁了身后的门。他关掉了所有的灯，这样从街上看过去，这栋房子就像是无人居住。他抓起电话，拨打了韦斯特菲尔德警察局的电话。一名警官被派往布勒瓦德657号，并阅读了德里克交给他的信。读完后，警官困惑地看着德里克。他问，这他妈的是什么？打印出来的信上写着：
Dearest the new neighbour at 657 Boulevard allow me to welcome you to the neighbourhood How did you end up here? Did 657 Boulevard call to you with its force within? 657 Boulevard has been the subject of my family for decades now and as it approaches its 110th birthday I have been putting charge of watching and waiting for its second coming My grandfather watched the house in the 1920s and my father watched it in the 1960s It is now my time Do you know the history of the house? Do you know what lies within the walls of 657 Boulevard? Why are you here? I will find out
布勒瓦德657号最亲爱的新邻居，请允许我欢迎你来到这个社区。你是怎么落脚这里的？布勒瓦德657号是用它内在的力量召唤了你吗？几十年来，布勒瓦德657号一直是我家族的主题，随着它即将迎来110岁生日，我被委任负责监视和等待它的第二次降临。我祖父在20世纪20年代守护着这栋房子，我父亲在20世纪60年代守护着它。现在轮到我了。你知道这栋房子的历史吗？你知道布勒瓦德657号的墙壁里藏着什么吗？你为什么来这里？我会查出来的。
I see already that you have flooded 657 Boulevard with contractors so that you can destroy their house as it was supposed to be Tisk, tisk, tisk, bad move. You don't want to make 657 Boulevard unhappy I asked the woods to bring me young blood and it looked like they listened You have children. I have seen them So far I think there are three that I have counted. Are there more on the way? Do you need to fill the house with the young blood I requested? Better for me Was your old house too small for the growing family or was it greed to bring me your children? Once I know their names, I will call them and draw them to me
我看到你已经用承包商塞满了布勒瓦德657号，这样你就可以像原本注定那样摧毁它的房子。啧，啧，啧，糟糕的举动。你不会想让布勒瓦德657号不开心的。我曾要求伍兹把新鲜血液带给我，看来他们听进去了。你们有孩子。我看到了。到目前为止，我数了一下有三个。还会有更多吗？你需要用我要求的年轻血液填满这栋房子吗？对我更好。你以前的房子对日益壮大的家庭来说太小了，还是贪婪驱使你把孩子带给我？一旦我知道他们的名字，我就会召唤他们，把他们吸引到我身边。
Who am I? There are hundreds and hundreds of cars that drive past 657 Boulevard each day Maybe I am in one Look at all the windows you can see from 657 Boulevard Maybe I am in one Look out any of the many windows in 657 Boulevard at all the people who stroll by each day Maybe I am one Welcome my friends, welcome. Let the party begin
我是谁？每天有成百上千辆汽车驶过布勒瓦德657号。也许我在其中。看看你可以从布勒瓦德657号看到的所有窗户。也许我在其中。看着布勒瓦德657号的任何一扇窗户外的每一个人，他们每天都在漫步。也许我就是其中之一。欢迎我的朋友们，欢迎。让派对开始吧。
Signed The Watcher Because they had been referred to in the letter, Derek Broadus emailed the previous owners of number 657 John and Andrea Woods mentioned the letter they had received from The Watcher just before vacating the property But insisted they weren't particularly concerned or distressed by its contents At the behest of the broadesses, both couples went to the Westfield Police Department to officially report the letters Assigned to the case was Detective Leonard Lugo He advised the broadesses to keep quiet about the letters, particularly to those who lived on the Boulevard He believed that The Watcher was someone who lived close by
署名：守望者。由于信中提到了他们，德里克·布罗杜斯发电子邮件给657号的前业主约翰和安德烈亚·伍兹。约翰和安德烈亚提到了他们在腾出房产前不久收到来自“守望者”的信，但坚称他们并没有对信中的内容感到特别担忧或苦恼。在布罗杜斯一家的要求下，两对夫妇前往韦斯特菲尔德警察局正式报告了这些信件。负责此案的是伦纳德·卢戈（Leonard Lugo）侦探。他建议布罗杜斯一家对这些信件保持沉默，尤其是对住在布勒瓦德的人。他相信“守望者”是一个住在附近的人。
A few days after receiving the letter, the broadesses attended a barbecue across the street to welcome them into the neighborhood According to New York Magazine, Derek and Maria were on high alert during the gathering They eyed others with suspicion and kept their children close The broadesses agreed to give one of their friendlier neighbors a tour of their beloved house Their anxiety heightened when the neighbor commented It will be nice to have some young blood in the neighborhood The renovations continued at 657 Two weeks after they received the unnerving letter, the broadesses had yet to move in
收到信几天后，布罗杜斯一家参加了街对面的烧烤派对，以欢迎他们加入社区。据《纽约杂志》（New York Magazine）报道，德里克和玛丽亚在聚会期间高度戒备。他们用猜疑的目光打量着其他人，并把孩子紧紧带在身边。布罗杜斯一家同意带他们一位比较友好的邻居参观他们心爱的房子。当邻居评论说“社区里能有一些年轻血液真是太好了”时，他们的焦虑加剧了。657号的翻修工作仍在继续。收到这封令人不安的信两周后，布罗杜斯一家还没有搬进去。
Maria called in to check the mail when she noticed a familiar looking envelope Instead of opening it, she took it directly to the Westfield Police Department The letter inside read Welcome again to your new home at 657 Boulevard The workers have been busy and I have been watching you unload carpools of your personal belongings The dumpster is a nice touch Have they found what is in the walls yet? In time they will
玛丽亚顺道来检查信件时，注意到一个熟悉的信封。她没有打开它，而是直接把它带到了韦斯特菲尔德警察局。里面的信写道：再次欢迎来到你位于布勒瓦德657号的新家。工人们一直很忙，而我一直在看着你卸下一车又一车你的私人物品。垃圾桶真是一个不错的点单。他们找到墙里藏着的东西了吗？时候到了他们会找到的。
I am pleased to know your names now and the name of the young blood you have brought to me You certainly say their names often 657 Boulevard is anxious for you to move in It has been years and years since the young blood ruled the hallways of the house Have you found all of the secrets it holds yet? Will the young blood play in the basement or are they too afraid to go down there alone? I would be very afraid if I were them It is far away from the rest of the house
我很高兴现在知道了你们的名字，以及你们带给我的年轻血液的名字。你们当然经常说出他们的名字。布勒瓦德657号渴望你们搬进来。年轻血液统治这座房子的走廊已经有很多很多年了。你们找到它所藏的所有秘密了吗？年轻血液会在地下室玩耍，还是他们太害怕而不敢独自下去？如果我是他们，我会非常害怕。它离房子的其他部分很远。
If you were upstairs, you would never hear them scream Will they sleep in the attic or will you all sleep on the second floor? Who has the bedrooms facing the street? I'll know as soon as you move in It will help me to know who is in which bedroom Then I can plan better All of the windows and doors in 657 Boulevard allow me to watch you and track you as you move through the house Who am I?
如果你在楼上，你永远不会听到他们的尖叫。他们会睡在阁楼里，还是你们都睡在二楼？谁的卧室朝街？你们一搬进来我就会知道。这会帮助我了解谁在哪个卧室。然后我可以更好地计划。布勒瓦德657号的所有窗户和门都让能够我看着你，并在你在房子里走动时追踪你。我是谁？
I am the watcher and have been in control of 657 Boulevard for the better part of two decades now The Woods family turned it over to you It was their time to move on and kindly sold it when I asked them to I passed by many times a day 657 Boulevard is my job, my life, my obsession And now you are too, broadest family Welcome to the product of your greed Greed is what brought the past three families to 657 Boulevard and now it has brought you to me
我是守望者，在过去二十年的大部分时间里一直控制着布勒瓦德657号。伍兹家族把它交给了你。那是他们继续前行的时候，在我要求时，他们客气地把它卖了。我一天经过很多次。布勒瓦德657号是我的工作、我的生活、我的痴迷。现在你也是了，布罗杜斯一家。欢迎来到你们贪婪的产物。贪婪是把过去三个家族带到布勒瓦德657号的原因，现在它把你带到了我这里。
The house is crying from all of the pain it is going through You have changed it and made it so fancy You are stealing its history It cries for the past and what used to be in the time when I roamed the halls The 1960s were a good time for 657 Boulevard when I ran from room to room Imagining life with the rich occupants there The house was full of life and young blood Then it got old and so did my father
房子在为它所经历的所有痛苦哭泣。你改变了它，把它弄得这么花哨。你在窃取它的历史。它为过去以及我漫步走廊的那个时代曾经存在的东西哭泣。20世纪60年代对布勒瓦德657号来说是个好时光，当时我在房间里跑来跑去，想象着那里富裕住户的生活。房子里充满了生机和年轻血液。然后它变老了，我父亲也老了。
But he kept watching until the day he died And now I watch and wait for the day when the young blood will be mine again Have a happy moving in day You know I will be watching The letter addressed the broadest by name and included the nicknames that Maria called her children The Westfield police conducted surveillance on 657 as Derek and Maria continued the renovations Stressed and on edge, they stopped allowing their children to visit the house And discussed whether they should move in at all
但他一直注视着，直到他死去的那一天。现在我注视着，等待着年轻血液再次属于我的那一天。祝你们搬家快乐。你知道我会注视着的。这封信点名了布罗杜斯，并包括了玛丽亚对她孩子的昵称。韦斯特菲尔德警方对657号进行了监视，而德里克和玛丽亚继续进行翻修。压力重重、神经紧绷的他们不再允许孩子参观这栋房子，并讨论他们是否应该搬进去。
A neighbour at 633 Boulevard came forward to say they had also received a letter from the watcher But they were not particularly concerned by it and had discarded it accordingly Derek and Maria were questioned about any enemies they might have None were identified Residing next door to 657 was a man named Michael Langford Michael had lived at the residence since the 1960s Coinciding with the watchers claim in their first letter that their father had watched the house since then Michael now lived with his mother who was in her 90s as well as several of his siblings who were in their 60s
布勒瓦德633号的一位邻居主动站出来说，他们也收到了来自守望者的信，但他们对此并不特别关心，并据此丢弃了它。德里克和玛丽亚被盘问他们可能有什么敌人。没有查明任何人。住在657号隔壁的是一个名叫迈克尔·兰福德（Michael Langford）的男子。迈克尔自20世纪60年代以来一直住在该住所，这与守望者在第一信中声称他们的父亲自那时起就一直监视这栋房子的说法相吻合。迈克尔现在和他的母亲（也90多岁了）以及他的几个60多岁的兄弟姐妹住在一起。
His father had died 12 years prior, again corresponding with the line in the second letter that asserted the watcher had been observing the property for the better part of two decades Known as being a bit odd to the Boulevard's residence, Michael was the first person who popped into the minds of investigators Diagnosed with schizophrenia, Michael was known to walk through backyards on the Boulevard and occasionally peer into windows He was taken in for questioning but denied being the watcher or penning any threats His family and those who knew Michael thought of him as a harmless character incapable of writing the letters With no evidence to keep him in custody, Michael Langford was released The watchers' letters and envelopes were sent for forensic testing No fingerprints were uncovered, but a DNA sample was extracted from the adhesive used to seal one of the envelopes
他的父亲在12年前去世，这再次与第二封信中坚称守望者一直在监视该房产将近二十年的说法相吻合。迈克尔被布勒瓦德的居民认为有点古怪，是第一个跳入调查人员脑海的人。迈克尔被诊断出患有精神分裂症，众所周知他在布勒瓦德的后院走来走去，偶尔窥视窗户。他被带走接受审问，但否认自己是守望者或写下任何威胁。他的家人和认识迈克尔的人认为他是一个无害的人物，没有能力写这些信。由于没有证据将他拘留，迈克尔·兰福德被释放了。守望者的信件和信封被送去进行法医鉴定。没有发现指纹，但从用于密封其中一个信封的胶粘剂中提取了DNA样本。
The DNA determined that whoever had sealed the envelopes was female Michael Langford's sister, Abby, was a real estate agent Police speculated that she might have been compelled to write the letters after she missed out on acquiring the properties listing herself They covertly retrieved a water bottle from her work desk From it, they extracted her DNA profile It was not a match to the DNA found on the envelope Former homeowner Angela Woods also provided a DNA sample, but it didn't match either The second letter sent to the broadesses also made mention of their daughter painting on an easel on the porch
DNA确定密封信封的人是女性。迈克尔·兰福德的妹妹艾比（Abby）是一名房地产经纪人。警方推测，她可能在错失获取该房产挂牌权后被迫写了这些信。他们秘密地从她的办公桌上取走了一个水瓶。从中，他们提取了她的DNA档案。它与信封上发现的DNA不匹配。前房主安吉拉·伍兹（Angela Woods）也提供了DNA样本，但也不匹配。寄给布罗杜斯的第二封信还提到了他们的女儿在门廊的画架上画画。
The close proximity of the Langfords to 657 Boulevard afforded them one of the few views from which the easel could be seen With police permission, the broadesses sent a letter to the Langfords It advised them that they planned to demolish the house on 657 Boulevard, hoping it would spark an outraged response They never received a reply With no arrests imminent, Derek received help from forensic linguist Robert Lanahan Robert carried out a threat assessment on the letters Based on their vocabulary and the two spaces after each full stop, he concluded that the writer was likely 50 to 60 years of age and a Navidad reader He browsed the local forums for language that resembled the contents of the letters
兰福德家族离布勒瓦德657号很近，这让他们拥有了少数能够看到画架的视线之一。在得到警方的许可下，布罗杜斯一家给兰福德家族写了一信。信中通知他们，他们计划拆除布勒瓦德657号的房子，希望这能引发愤怒的反应。他们从未收到回复。由于没有即将进行的逮捕，德里克得到了法医语言学家罗伯特·拉纳汉（Robert Lanahan）的帮助。罗伯特对这些信件进行了威胁评估。根据它们的词汇量以及每个句号后的两个空格，他得出结论，写信者可能是50到60岁，并且是一个纳维达（Navidad）读者。他浏览了当地的论坛，寻找与信件内容相似的语言。
There were no matches A private investigator Derek Hyde staked out the neighborhood Although they determined that the Langfords were strange, they were unable to unearth the watcher Derek even turned to a former FBI agent who had inspired the character of Clarice Starling in Silence of the Lambs, but to no avail Derek Broadess was certain that the Langford family were responsible He poured over council plans to see which houses had views of his property and who would be able to hear his children being called He also set up multiple webcams around his house According to New York Magazine, one day a house painter at the property was working when he noticed something strange
没有匹配项。私家侦探德里克·海德（Derek Hyde）监视了该社区。尽管他们确定兰福德一家很奇怪，但他们无法发掘出守望者。德里克甚至求助于一位曾启发《沉默的羔羊》（Silence of the Lambs）中克拉丽丝·史达琳（Clarice Starling）角色的前FBI特工，但也无济于事。德里克·布罗杜斯确信兰福德家族是罪魁祸首。他仔细研究了市议会的规划，看看哪些房子可以看到他的房产，谁能听到他的孩子被叫喊。他还在房子周围安装了多个网络摄像头。据《纽约杂志》报道，一天，房产的一名油漆工正在工作，当时他注意到一件奇怪的事情。
He looked out one of the rear windows The neighbors behind 657 had placed the deck chairs in very close proximity to the boundary of the two properties Instead of facing their own house, the couple positioned the chairs to look straight at 657 The couple sat on the chairs, watching the workers as they renovated Upon investigating this couple, it was discovered that their daughter had married a man who lived in 657 previously The promising lead went nowhere All former owners and housekeepers of 657 were also ruled out one by one At 11 o'clock one night, police staking out the boulevard observed a car slow to a stop outside 657
他向后窗外望去。657号后面的邻居把躺椅放在离两处房产边界非常近的地方。这对夫妇没有面向自己的房子，而是把椅子摆好，直视657号。这对夫妇坐在椅子上，看着工人们装修。在调查这对夫妇时，发现他们的女儿嫁给了一个以前住在657号的人。这一有希望的线索无果而终。657号的所有前业主和管家也一一被排除。一天晚上11点，监视布勒瓦德的警察看到一辆车在657号外面减速停车。
The driver remained motionless in the vehicle for some time before driving away The car was traced to a woman who resided in a nearby suburb When questioned, she claimed that her boyfriend was driving her car He lived in very close proximity to 657 boulevard However, at the time, he was living in a different location She said her boyfriend was known to play some really dark video games One character he played was called the Watcher Police contacted the boyfriend who agreed to an interview
司机在车里静止了一段时间才开走。这辆车被追溯到住在附近郊区的一名女子。当被盘问时，她声称她的男朋友开着她的车。他住在离布勒瓦德657号非常近的地方。然而，当时他住在另一个地方。她说她的男朋友以玩一些非常黑暗的视频游戏而闻名。他玩的一个角色叫守望者。警方联系了同意接受采访的男朋友。
When he didn't show, a second interview was scheduled He didn't turn up for that one either Without concrete evidence to link this man to being the Watcher, investigators hands were tied The man had no legal obligation to assist police with their investigations The broadesses faced the conundrum They had a beautifully renovated house made to their specifications But were too afraid to move in Derek spent some nights in the attic with the lights off looking out the windows with a pair of binoculars
当他没有出现时，安排了第二次采访。他也没有出席那场。在没有确凿证据将这个人与守望者联系起来的情况下，调查人员束手无策。这名男子没有法律义务协助警方进行调查。布罗杜斯一家面临着一个难题。他们有一栋根据他们的要求精美翻修过的房子，但太害怕而不敢搬进去。德里克在阁楼里过了一些关灯的夜晚，用一双双筒望远镜向窗外张望。
But the Watcher never made an appearance The broadest family moved in with Maria's parents and their grand house sat empty In February 2015, six months after they had purchased the property The broadesses put 657 boulevard back on the market They asked for nearly $1.5 million, $100,000 more than they had purchased it for With the home's extensive renovations, the skyrocketing real estate market And location in one of New Jersey's premier neighborhoods, it should have been a quick sell However, the Watcher had come to the attention of the local media
但守望者从未露面。布罗杜斯一家搬到了玛丽亚的父母家，他们的大房子空着。2015年2月，即他们购买该房产六个月后，布罗杜斯一家将布勒瓦德657号重新挂牌出售。他们要价近150万美元，比他们买下它的价格高出10万美元。凭借房子的广泛翻修、飙升的房地产市场以及位于新泽西州首要社区之一的位置，这本应该是一次快速的出售。然而，守望者已经引起了当地媒体的注意。
And there were no interested buyers In June 2015, the broadesses filed a lawsuit against the previous owners of 657 John and Andrea Woods According to the morning call, they argued that they never would have bought the property Had they known there was a person who had a quote Mentally disturbed fixation on the house The broadesses were suing for fraud and concealment They believed that the woods should have disclosed the property
并且没有感兴趣的买家。2015年6月，布罗杜斯一家对657号的前业主约翰和安德烈亚·伍兹提起诉讼。据《晨报》（The Morning Call）报道，他们辩称，如果他们知道有一个人对这栋房子有引述“精神错乱的执念”，他们绝不会买下这房产。布罗杜斯一家起诉欺诈和隐瞒。他们认为伍兹应该披露该房产。
They believed that the woods should have disclosed that they had received a letter from the Watcher Prior to vacating the house They wanted the woods to refund them the purchase price of the house as well as punitive damages The lawyer for the broadesses explained that they had attempted to sell the house because They are unable to live in the home without extreme anxiety and fear for their children's safety and well-being The woods maintained that the letter they received from the Watcher was not threatening They countersued the broadesses, claiming they had been defamed by the lawsuit Which was gaining considerable media attention
他们认为伍兹应该透露他们收到了来自守望者的信件。在腾出房子之前。他们希望伍兹退还房子的购买价格以及惩罚性赔偿。布罗杜斯一家的律师解释说，他们曾试图出售房子，因为他们无法在没有极端焦虑和对孩子安全和福祉的恐惧的情况下住在家里。伍兹坚称他们从守望者那里收到的信并不具有威胁性。他们反诉布罗杜斯，声称他们因诉讼而名誉扫地，该诉讼获得了相当大的媒体关注。
While waiting for the civil suit to be heard, the broadess family rented out 657 Their tenants were fully aware of the bizarre goings on at the home The parties had a special rental agreement It featured a clause that gave the tenants permission to vacate the house should another letter from the Watcher arrive With no children and two large dogs to protect them The tenants felt confident enough to sign the lease In February 2017, a few weeks after they moved in An envelope appeared in their letter box
在等待民事诉讼审理期间，布罗杜斯一家将657号出租了。他们的租客完全清楚家里发生的奇异事情。双方有一份特殊的租赁协议。它具有一个条款，如果收到来自守望者的另一封信，则赋予租客腾出房子的权限。在没有孩子和两只大狗保护他们的情况下，租客有足够的信心签署租约。2017年2月，他们搬进来几周后，一个信封出现在他们的信箱里。
It had been two years since the last letter from the Watcher had been received This time, the envelope was addressed Violent winds and bitter cold To the vile and spiteful Derek and his wench of a wife, Maria The letter inside asked Where have you gone to? 657 Boulevard is missing you 657 Boulevard is missing you The letter was confiscated by the Westfield Police Department
距离收到上一封来自守望者的信已经过去两年了。这一次，信封上的收件人是：狂风暴雨和刺骨的寒冷。致邪恶和恶毒的德里克和他的荡妇妻子玛丽亚。里面的信问道：你们去哪里了？布勒瓦德657号想念你们。布勒瓦德657号想念你们。这封信被韦斯特菲尔德警察局没收了。
Who initially kept its contents confidential Forensic testing failed to uncover any fingerprints or DNA on the letter or its envelope The tenants agreed to stay on Despite the remainder of the letter containing increasingly violent threats towards the occupants of the house Their only condition was that the broadesses install additional security cameras Derek promptly did so In another desperate attempt to offload the house, which was now causing them a significant financial burden The broadesses applied to the Westfield Planning Board
他们最初对内容保密。法医鉴定未能在这封信或其信封上发现任何指纹或DNA。租客同意留下来。尽管信件的其余部分包含对屋内住客日益严重的暴力威胁。他们唯一的条件是布罗杜斯安装额外的安全摄像。德里克很快照做了。在另一次绝望的尝试中，试图卸下这栋现在给他们带来沉重经济负担的房子，布罗杜斯向韦斯特菲尔德规划委员会申请。
Their plan was to raise the house they had put so much work into And subdivide the land into two lots to sell Residents in Westfield protested the proposal They argued that smaller lots would be out of character for the community In March 2017, the Planning Board formally rejected the plan They cited that at 67.4 and 67.6 feet respectively The subdivided lots would fall 2.5 feet short of the mandated 70-foot required allotment In a further bout of bad luck, the civil case lodged by the broadesses was thrown out in October 2017
他们的计划是拆除他们投入了大量心血的房子，并将土地细分为两个地块出售。韦斯特菲尔德的居民抗议这一提议。他们认为较小的地块不符合社区的特色。2017年3月，规划委员会正式拒绝了该计划。他们指出，在分别为67.4英尺和67.6英尺的情况下，细分地块将比规定的70英尺所需分配短2.5英尺。在又一次倒霉中，布罗杜斯提出的民事诉讼在2017年10月被驳回。
It was determined that the case could set an unreasonable precedent for what sellers would need to disclose to potential buyers The broadesses put 657 Boulevard back on the market for the reduced price of $1.1 million The mysterious watcher left the idyllic Westfield area in a state of unease Police assured the public that they had conducted a thorough investigation But admittedly, were no closer to solving the case A journalist from a local newspaper speculated that the broadesses themselves could have been responsible for the letters He theorised that the family might have gotten in over their heads with the mortgage And were looking for a way to wriggle out of their financial troubles
经确定，该案可能会为卖家需要向潜在买家披露的内容开创不合理的先例。布罗杜斯一家将布勒瓦德657号以110万美元的降价重新挂牌出售。神秘的守望者让田园诗般的韦斯特菲尔德地区处于不安状态。警方向公众保证，他们已经进行了彻底的调查，但不可否认的是，距离破案并没有更近。来自当地报纸的一位记者推测，布罗杜斯一家自己可能要对这些信件负责。他推测这个家庭可能用房贷把自己逼入了绝境，并正在寻找摆脱财务困境的方法。
Another theory was that the broadesses concocted the entire series of events in order to profit from a potential television or movie deal The broadesses angrily denied these allegations They also copped flak on social media, with users calling them cowards for being scared away from moving into their home by a couple of letters Maria Broadess even took a DNA test to rule herself out as a suspect Derek Broadess told The Today Show, I was a depressed rack On July 1, 2019, Derek and Maria Broadess sold 657 Boulevard to another couple for just over $959,000 $400,000 less than they had purchased the property for five years earlier This also didn't cover the significant amount of money they put into renovations
另一个理论是，布罗杜斯捏造了整个系列事件，以便从潜在的电视或电影交易中获利。布罗杜斯愤怒地否认了这些指控。他们还在社交媒体上招致抨击，用户称他们为懦夫，因为他们被几封信吓得不敢搬进自己的家里。玛丽亚·布罗杜斯甚至做了DNA测试，以排除自己作为嫌疑人的可能。德里克·布罗杜斯告诉《今日秀》（The Today Show）：我是一个沮丧的废人。2019年7月1日，德里克和玛丽亚·布罗杜斯以略多于959,000美元的价格将布勒瓦德657号卖给了另一对夫妇，比他们五年前购买该房产的价格低了400,000美元。这也无法弥补他们投入装修的巨额资金。
According to all that's interesting, Maria Broadess said At the end of the day, it came down to, what are you going to risk? We weren't going to put our kids in harm's way The broadesses decided to stay in Westfield, purchasing a modest home in an undisclosed location The watcher eyed the blank sheet of paper before them With pen in hand, they began scribbling across its surface You wonder who the watcher is? Turn around, idiots Maybe you even spoke to me, one of the so-called neighbors who has no idea who the watcher could be
据《这一切都很有趣》（All That's Interesting）报道，玛丽亚·布罗杜斯说：归根结底，取决于你要冒什么险？我们不会把我们的孩子置于危险之中。布罗杜斯决定留在韦斯特菲尔德，在一个未公开的地方买了一栋简朴的房子。守望者看着他们面前的白纸。手里拿着笔，他们开始在表面上乱涂乱画。你想知道谁是守望者吗？转过身去，笨蛋们。也许你甚至和我交过手，那些不知道谁可能是守望者的所谓邻居之一。
Or maybe you do know and are too scared to tell anyone Good move I walked by the news trucks when they took over my neighborhood and mocked me I watched as you watched from the dark house in an attempt to find me Telescopes and binoculars are wonderful inventions They went on to detail how they might cause the Broadess family's demise Maybe a car accident, maybe a fire Maybe something as simple as a mild illness that never seems to go away
或者也许你知道并且太害怕而不敢告诉任何人。好招。当新闻卡车接管我的社区并嘲笑我时，我从旁边走过。我看着你从黑暗的房子里注视着，企图找到我。望远镜和双筒望远镜是伟大的发明。他们接着详细说明了他们如何可能导致布罗杜斯一家的消亡。也许是车祸，也许是火灾，也许是像永远不会消失的轻微疾病那样简单的事情。
But makes you feel sick day after day after day after day Maybe the mysterious death of a pet, loved ones suddenly die Planes and cars and bicycles crash Bones break The watcher then folded the letter and slid it inside an envelope They sealed it shut and rode across its front To the vile and spiteful Derek and his wench of a wife, Maria The letter ended
但让你日复一日、日复一日、日复一日地感到生病。也许是宠物的神秘死亡，挚爱的亲人突然离世。飞机、汽车和自行车相撞。骨头断裂。然后守望者把信折叠起来，塞进信封里。他们把它密封起来，并在正面写上：致邪恶和恶毒的德里克和他的荡妇妻子玛丽亚。信的结尾是：
You are despised by the house and the watcher won This was the final letter penned to the Broadess family by the watcher in 2017 No further letters have reportedly been sent to 657 Boulevard since The watcher remains unknown To be continued There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你被这栋房子鄙视了，守望者赢了。这是2017年守望者写给布罗杜斯一家的最后一封信。据报道，此后没有更多的信件寄往布勒瓦德657号。守望者仍然是个未知数。未完待续。本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。